>>> IF YOU'RE OVER 45, THAT
MEANS IT'S TIME TO START
SCREENING FOR CLONE CANCER, AND
THERE'S NO EASIER WAY TO DO IT
THAN WITH COLOGUARD, THE SIMPLE
BOX DELIVERED TO YOUR DOORSTEP.
>> CAN I HELP YOU?
>> HI.
I'M COLOGUARD.
>> OH, YEAH, MY DOCTOR ORDERED
YOU.
>> THAT'S RIGHT.
BECAUSE I'M SAFE, EASY TO USE.
>> HOW'S IT WORK?
>> I JUST NEED TO COLLECT A
SAMPLE, SO OPEN ME UP AND GO
INSIDE ME.
>> INSIDE YOU?
>> YEAH, JUST GO INSIDE ME.
IT'S OKAY.
I LIKE IT.
>> ARE YOU GOING TO LOOK AT ME
LIKE THAT WHILE I DO IT?
>> SURE.
I'M JUST SMILING BECAUSE I LOVE
MY JOB, AND I LOVE WHAT YOU'RE
ABOUT TO DO TO ME.
>> WELL, I DON'T LOVE THAT YOU
HAVE A FACE AND A LITTLE MOUTH.
>> AND A NAME.
I'M THOMAS.
>> WHY DO I HATE KNOWING THAT?
>> COME ON, IT'S FUN FOR BOTH OF
US.
YOU GET THE SATISFACTION OF
KNOWING YOU'RE DOING EVERYTHING
YOU CAN TO PROTECT YOUR COLON,
AND I GET ANOTHER KIND OF
SATISFACTION.
SO GO AHEAD, UNLOAD IN ME.
>> WHY IS THE U.P.S. GUY
WATCHING?
>> HE'S WAITING TO COLLECT THE
SAMPLE AFTER YOU'RE DONE.
>> GO AHEAD, UNLEASH.
>> I DON'T FEEL COMFORTABLE
DOING THIS IN FRONT OF YOU GUYS.
>> WOULD YOU FEEL MORE
COMFORTABLE UNLOADING ON A
LITTLE WOMAN LIKE ME?
WOULD THAT MAKE YOU FEEL LIKE A
REAL MAN?
>> GOD, NO.
I JUST WANT TO BE SCREENED FOR
COLON CANCER.
>> THEN GO AHEAD, DESTROY ME,
DADDY, BLOW MY BOX OPEN.
>> YEAH, I WANT TO SEE YOU BLOW
THAT BOX WIDE OPEN.
>> THIS IS SICK.
>> BUT NOT SICK FROM COLON
CANCER.
SO JUST GO INSIDE HER, THEN PASS
THE SUPER WARM BOX TO THE U.P.S.
GUY.
>> GET IT NICE AND WARM BEFORE
YOU HAND IT BACK TO ME.
>> I'LL EVEN CLOSE MY EYES WHILE
YOU DO IT.
>> I SEE YOU PEEKING.
HOW MANY OF YOU ARE THERE?
>> IT'S OKAY.
WE'RE JUST HERE TO WATCH.
>> WE'RE FRIENDLY LIKE MINIONS,
SO GO AHEAD AND UNLEASH.
>> STOP SAYING UNLEASH.
>> WOULD IT HELP IF YOU KNEW
THEIR NAMES?
THAT'S KYLIE, VICTOR, NEIL, AND
SHEVAT.
>> WE CAN'T WAIT TO SEE YOU
UNLEASH.
>> I'M ACTUALLY GOOD.
I JUST REMEMBERED THAT I
SCREENED FOR COLON CANCER LAST
YEAR, SO.
>> AND YOU WOULDN'T BE LYING TO
US, RIGHT?
>> OF COURSE NOT.
>> BECAUSE WE CAN ALSO DETECT
LIARS.
>> NOW DROP YOUR PANTS, BLOW OUT
HIS BOX, AND THIS WILL ALL BE
OVER.
>> JUST DO WHAT THE LITTLE BOXES
SAY TO DO.
>> I'LL GIVE YOU WHAT YOU WANT,
JUST PLEASE DON'T KILL ME.
>> MAN, IS WOODY OKAY?
>> I KNOW HE SMOKES A TON OF
WEED, BUT I'M REALLY STARTING TO
WORRY ABOUT HIM.
>> OH.
ALL RIGHT.
LET'S HEAD INSIDE AND GIVE HIM
SOME PRIVACY.
>> ACTUALLY, I'M GOING TO STAY.
I'M GOING TO WATCH HIM UNLEASH.
>> COLOGUARD, GO AHEAD, WE LIKE
IT.